en deux ans de loi contre les exclusions
4 millions et demi de personnes ont déjà
bénéficié de soins gratuits grâce à la
cmu la couverture maladie universelle
montant de la facture 7 milliards 7 côté
logements pour les familles défavorisées
le crédit a été augmenté de 44% en deux
ans avec 6 milliard et demi de francs
supplémentaires depuis 98 des mesures
encore insuffisantes pour les
associations d aide aux plus démunis
je crois que le chemin est encore long
notamment par exemple pas accéder au
logement social si vous n'avez pas les
ressources suffisantes si vous avez un
parcours de ressources qui est
interrompue de temps en temps mais elle
est le propriétaire vous acceptera pas
dans un logement par exemple
autre mesure le programme nouveau départ
il s'agit de contrats de réinsertion
professionnelle passée entre l'anpe et
des chômeurs de longue durée ou des
jeunes un million quatre cent mille
personnes en ont bénéficié coût 20
milliards de francs enfin la loi permet
aussi à ceux qui perçoivent une
allocation de l'état de la conserver
tout en ayant un emploi 15% de rmistes
hall ont fait ce n'est qu'un bilan
provisoire de la loi contre les
exclusions adoptée en 1998